well what's the most amazing golf shot
that you've ever made
oh uh recently actually recently i was
competing in this uh um college golf
showcase not
in college myself but i was asked to
join this group
and compete for charity so it was like
darius rucker
and myself were on a team and jerome
bettis
and um brian urlacher yeah they were on
another team and we had two college kids
so it was four against four
we were playing out in arizona and we
were losing and it came down to the last
hole the 18th hole
final hole final putt 100 000
putt this is like a movie yeah it really
felt like a hundred thousand dollar putt
for charity all the way across the green
i'm calling it 75 feet at least
and i'm making um i'm gonna be real with
you i've seen this
and i thought it was incredible so i'm
gonna show the two oh good it's amazing
yes wriggle for 100 000
i bet he likes the sound of that
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
the golfers out there know they know i'm
not a golfer and you're a superhero to
me right now
i watched that because i was i was like
oh he's come back on there like yeah
he's this incredible
golf shot and i watched it last night
and i was like screw this guy
i was like you made that putt i was like
i couldn't i can't even make it next to
the hole
like i'm real i'm like happy gilmore i
can drive the ball but i can't putt for
anything
but that was incredible i felt very
blessed
like you were flying did you feel like
you were the coolest person in the world
can i tell you i i actually had the the
honest reaction
i i turned into a soccer player all of a
sudden i
ran away from my teammates and i ran
away and it was like
look what i did yeah and then i realized
oh don't do that and i turned around and
ran back to them
so you can actually see it i like it i
got embarrassed that i ran away because
i
i'm not a soccer player i'm a team
player no i know but whatever
it's a it was a great goal if you're a
soccer player so it's fine
um you're incredible at golf so there's
that yep
i'm still here just waiting for you to
subscribe if you don't i'll be trapped
in this box forever
help